you'd think working on one of the
biggest movie franchises of all time
would make actors nothing but smiles yet
some of the biggest names in the Harry
Potter series actually had parts of the
job they hated let's take the train back
to Hogwarts and find out more Mr Potter
himself Daniel Radcliffe was not only
first on the call sheet but also first
on the list of actors who struggled with
the movies but to be honest when you
think about some of Daniel's reasons
they make sense for starters there were
some specific scenes he struggled with
like in the Goblet of Fire he has to
pretend to fall from the top of the
castle while being chased by a dragon
now before you start shouting at the
screen I'm aware both the castle and the
dragon were CGI but they still had to
put Radcliffe on a wire and drop him
like really fast to make it look real
because it was very very physical and
what is real is that it scared the
Living Daylights out of him and speaking
of uncomfortable scenes he also didn't
particularly enjoy all the Quidditch
scenes not because of the heights but
because they'd strap him to a broomstick
for hours an hour hours and as you can
imagine the broomstick was in a fairly
sensitive area of his body we'll just
leave it there Radcliffe also had issues
with the process as a whole he and the
other child actors had basically zero
acting experience going in so they were
learning how to act while doing it in
front of an entire set for a cast and
crew and on camera for the world to see
it was arguably the most anticipated
series of all time too that's a lot of
pressure for an actor regardless of age
so he avoids watching the movies unless
he has to I see them at the at the
premiere and then if I can I avoid ever
watching you avoid them yes because when
Daniel does look back at the early
movies especially he gets really
frustrated at his performances he's on
record saying that when he watches them
he sees himself making acting mistakes
that like everyone makes at the
beginning of their career but unlike
everyone else he didn't get to make them
in an acting class or a rehearsal room
instead they're permanently out there
for the world to see I think it would
just be it's you know it's like passing
around baby photos of yourself it's not
an enjoyable experience but his issues
with his acting go further than that
even as far as the sixth movie the Half
Blood Prince he doesn't like his
performance he's called it one note and
accuses himself of being complacent
about the process though I should note
he had nice things to say about what he
did in the Order of the Phoenix so
that's something but unfortunately the
issues for Daniel extended to more than
just cringing at the movies the pressure
of the gig actually led to him
developing a drinking problem he's
talked about having an addictive
personality and the scrutiny and
pressures of being the one and only
Harry Potter definitely made that side
of him come out he was drinking every
day and not just like casual sips he did
make sure to say he was never drinking
while he filmed the movies and
fortunately he was able to get the
problem under control and quit drinking
altogether in 2010. as we all know
Daniel wasn't the only kid actor having
to learn how to act while on camera Emma
Watson has talked about having the same
frustration as Daniel only with an added
twist early on as Emma was filming she
had a kind of hilarious habit of
mouthing along to everyone else's lines
as they said them a stone that may skull
stops you from dying now one of the
Snipes after it which to be honest is a
total Hermione Granger move am I right
but it wasn't hilarious to Emma
this is actually quite traumatic for me
she also had issues throughout the
series with her independence or rather
her lack of one she's talked about how
tough it was to basically have every
minute of all her days mapped out for
her minute by minute and how she didn't
have any control over it so she was told
when she'd be picked up and brought to
the set when to eat and when there was
enough time between shots for her to use
the restroom it got under her skin so
much she seriously considered leaving
the series halfway through the strain of
Fame was another factor and hers was
maybe even worse than Daniel Radcliffe's
in the sense that she had to deal with a
literal stalker a dude showed up at her
school one day trying to find her and
from then on she had to hire private
bodyguards to protect her like Radcliffe
Emma also had particular movies and
scenes she hated shooting for starters
she talked about how the shoot for
Deathly Hallows part 1 involved a ton of
outdoor shots that took forever it was a
grueling process that was just a little
too intense for Emma but she even had
issues with some indoor scenes too like
when she had to wear a dress and enter
the ballroom to dance with Victor Crump
she got so like flummoxed with all the
directions that the director was
shouting at her she ended up falling
down the stairs oof and maybe the
hardest shot for her was inside the
Chamber of Secrets in Deathly Hallows
Part 2 not because of anything
physically rigorous but because she had
to kiss Rupert rent AKA Ron Weasley the
two are close friends and have been
basically growing up together on set so
to her it felt like kissing a sibling
hey you know what feels like the
opposite of kissing a sibling
subscribing to the channel just saying
anyway Emma wasn't alone in that
particular feeling Rupert talked about
how strange it was to kiss his friend
and that they were both super
self-conscious as they slowly leaned in
he said he was relieved when it only
took him four takes to get the shot and
like Daniel Radcliffe Rupert also had
his issues with the Quidditch scenes for
the same uncomfortable reasons you guys
I think it's safe to say that nobody
likes to have trouble sitting after
spending hours with a broomstick wedged
between their legs plus Rod had the
added fun of being smacked one time in
the face by a quaffle I always assumed
those were done with CGI but apparently
they're real so now I'm questioning
everything but that's my own burden
don't worry about me Rupert also has
Arachnophobia AKA fear of spiders so it
was not super fun for him to film the
scene where he has to face a giant
spider aragog because even though the
final product had a CG spider they still
tried some takes with an animatronic one
too I had a full-on panic attack and we
never did it again Rupert's also talked
about the fact that Not only was he
never trying to act as a career but he's
also a total introvert so that's
probably not a great combo when you
become one of the most famous child
actors in the world he had a really hard
time adjusting to his total lack of
anonymity even going so far as to say
it's like having a split personality
like he's almost had to create a
different personality in his mind for
when he's out and getting bombarded by
fans and people taking photos yikes he
even talked about quitting acting after
the series ended not necessarily because
he didn't enjoy it but because he felt
like he'd missed out on having a normal
childhood so he was just looking to be a
real person out in the world for a while
and I'm sure the fact that he had
already made several lifetimes worth of
money from the movies made the idea of
quitting a little less scary besides our
main Trio there were some other actors
who took issue with elements of being in
the Potter movies but he was still super
heartthrobby as Cedric Diggory sadly
Cedric dies at the hands of Voldemort
and this scene was pretty uncomfortable
for Mr Twilight to film to make his body
contort in the right way for the death
to look real they had to wrap a wire
around his um groin region and then they
propelled him backwards it was quite
unpleasant on his little diggeries he
also said it was really hard filming all
the underwater scenes Dame Maggie Smith
didn't have any underwater scenes but
she still found the whole process
unpleasant and not for reasons you might
expect Smith AKA Professor Minerva
McGonagall is a legend of acting
particularly in Britain her issues have
less to do with the Harry Potter series
itself and more about movies and TV as
mediums she's such a fanatic for stage
acting that she finds movie and TV roles
to be pretty unsatisfying and that
includes both the Potter series and her
incredible role in Downton Abbey she
also didn't really care for the heavy
weight of the hats they had her wear in
Harry Potter but that seems pretty
reasonable please don't make older folks
wear unnecessarily heavy clothing people
the costuming wasn't too much of a
burden on the late great Alan Rickman
but he had other issues he of course
played Professor Severus Snape and
despite absolutely nailing the role and
endearing himself to a younger
generation of fans who don't know about
the amazingness of Hans Gruber he wasn't
super happy with his part after Rickman
died some of his letters were sold at an
auction and in them there were some
disparaging things he had written about
the Journey of Snape over the course of
the movies he apparently felt like one
of the directors David Yates was
abandoning some of the potential
character Arc for Snape in an effort to
Simply appeal to teens of course since
that's exactly who the movie was
marketed to it's hard to fault Yates for
that finally we have John Cleese one of
the most revered comic actors of all
time and a member of the legendary Monty
Python sketch group while on Graham
Norton's talk show he was seated next to
Taylor Swift Harry Potter who mentioned
what a big fan she was of the Potter
movies Lisa's reaction was pretty
dismaying to Taylor basically slamming
the movies it was awful and I can see
his point really the movies are like 90
CGI so I can imagine that actors who
have been at it for years acting
opposite a green screen or a mop with a
head on it might be pretty boring so
apparently making hit movies is not all
butterflies and rainbows you guys or
maybe I should say it's not all dragons
and Patronus charms either way I'm just
glad all these actors stuck it out and
gave us this awesome series if you know
of any more fun behind the scenes info
about the actors from Potter pop them in
the comments